[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à quoi ça sert un artiste vous pensez
peut-être comme la l'immense majorité
des gens qu un artiste ça délivrent des
messages
quand on demandait à picasso m quel est
votre message
il répondait mais quel message nsuite
pas facteur un artiste c'est là pour
poser des questions à lui même d'abord
ou public ensuite qui pourra s'en saisir
et cela posé à son tour de la question
n'est la réflexion qui engendrera
l'action l'anthropocène gilles vous en a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est le joli nom
qu'un grand nombre de météorologues et
de géologues donne à la période actuelle
de l'histoire de notre planète
anthropocène c'est un néologisme
construit à partir de deux mots grec
anthropos êtres humains et casino ce
nouveau en référence cette nouvelle
période où la contrainte géologique
dominante c'est devenu l'activité
humaine
c'est l'homme aujourd'hui qui modifie
son environnement qui modifie la planète
et de façon extrêmement dangereuse je ne
fait que compléter
mais là où il y as danger croît ce qui
sauva la célèbre phrase du poète
friedrich hölderlin n'a jamais été
autant d'actualité
les extraordinaires moyens
technologiques qui ont permis la
surexploitation des ressources
ce génie humain peut-être mis à mon sens
en miroir au service de la rédemption de
la réparation
nous pouvons tous agir
pas seulement les ingénieurs les
scientifiques les techniciens n'ont tous
vous madame vous monsieur mois
mais pour cela nous devons résister
résister à l'ambiance dépressive
résister à la fatalité
résister c'est combattre l'instinct
grégaire qui est en chacun d'entre nous
et là je veux parler de consommation
vous inquiétez pas je vais pas vous dire
faut tous couler à vélo s'éclairer à la
bougie et vivent sous des tipis
non je pense plus sérieusement que nous
pouvons le plus souvent possible
réfléchir et peser les réelles
conséquences de nos actes d'achat par
exemple s'acheter un écran plat plus
grands un ordinateur plus puissant une
voiture plus confortable ou même une
fringue
j'agis en tant que citoyen mais j'agis
aussi en tant qu'artiste aujourd'hui je
veux mettre mon savoir faire au service
du faire savoir
la surexploitation des ressources
naturelles a eu pour conséquence entre
autres la disparition d'un grand nombre
d'espèces animales en 42 ans nous avons
perdu 58% de la faune planétaire dont
38% de vertébrés terrestres
s'il ya aussi les poissons les oiseaux
les animaux justement il se trouve que
c'est mon truc
mes peintures animalières se vendent
dans très nombreuses galeries dans le
monde se vendent très bien et je
pourrais continuer à vivre très
confortablement de ce travail sans me
poser de questions mais j'ai décidé de
m'engager d'agir
si un artiste ne peut pas agir
directement sur les causes de
l'extinction sur les causes du déclin il
peut en revanche tenté par la puissance
de ses oeuvres
autant que faire se peut de convaincre
de rallier le plus grand nombre à
soutenir ceux qui luttent pour la
préservation de la biodiversité par des
dons pour financer les programmes de
conservation qui coûte très cher je vous
rappelle à cette occasion que la
première campagne de barack obama pour
les élections présidentielles
américaines de 2008 a été largement
financé par des dons de 5 à 30 dollars
cette année en partenariat avec la
fondation prince albert ii de monaco
nous avons présenté la première campagne
delete deal it est une oeuvre que j'ai
créée pour sensibiliser les populations
urbaines à la menace qui pèse sur un
grand nombre d'espèces alors que peindre
pour rallier pour convaincre pour
séduire lors de nos premières réunions
avec mes partenaires de la fondation en
2015 on en a beaucoup discuté
les scientifiques pensent que à raison
un j'imagine pense que la perte des
batraciens et beaucoup plus dommageable
pour l'humanité que celle des éléphants
mais je ne voulais pas peindre
d'éléphants alors je me suis rappelé de
cette histoire qui m'avait beaucoup
marqué savez vous qui a fait ça
il s'appelait vraiment de louis c'est le
père du design industriel
on lui doit aussi le logo des biscuits
lu le paquet de lucky strike
la stat baker beaucoup de produits pour
cac colas pour coca cola enfin bref des
visuels mondialement connue vraiment de
louis quand il était jeune designer dans
les années 40-50 pour chercher de
nouveaux clients
ils allaient sur les foires industriels
voire les fabricants sur leur stand et
leur disais votre produit
il est super il marche vraiment bien il
est très efficace mais bon sang
qu'est-ce qu'il est laid s'il était beau
vous en vendriez beaucoup plus et moi je
peux vous le rendre beau et ça a été le
leitmotiv de sa vie le bo fait vendre
pour vendre une idée il ne suffit pas
qu'elle soit belle philanthropique man
ou philosophiquement
il faut aussi qu'elle soit belle
esthétiquement plastiquement
artistiquement parce que l'image
c'est la première chose qui vous saisit
dans l'espace public
c'est l'image qui va vous convaincre de
vouloir en savoir plus bien avant le son
bien avant toute autre forme
l'image donc j'ai réussi à convaincre
mes partenaires d'aller droit au but est
de montrer de grands et beaux mammifères
comme panthera tigris
alpiq a pointé gras tigris i'll take a
c'est le nom taxonomique du tigre de
sibérie ou tigre de l'amour c'est le
plus puissant de toutes les sous espèces
de tigres
c'est aussi le 3e plus grands prédateurs
terrestres après l'ours kodiak et l'ours
polaire les grands mâles peuvent peser
jusqu'à 350 400 kg et mesurer jusqu'à 3
mètres 80 au bout de la queue
le tigre de sibérie
vie au nord-est de la chine et en
sibérie orientale le long du fleuve
amour d'où son nom qui est la frontière
naturelle entre les deux grands pays il
vit sur un très vaste territoire mais
qui est aussi un endroit
géopolitiquement très stratégique en
effet c'est là que passe le plus grand
oléoduc du monde
le 'pipeline' espoo espoo va de la
sibérie orientale jusqu'au pacifique sur
plus de 4000 km et en 2020 il livrera
plus de 80 millions de tonnes de pétrole
brut à la chine ou japon à la corée pour
un montant global annuel de 125
milliards de dollars oui là on est dans
du lourd 1 alors la construction dspo
bien sûr a nécessité de la déforestation
ce qui a considérablement réduit enfin
considérablement partiellement réduit
l'habitat du tigre mais aussi a ouvert
de nouvelles routes qui facilite l'accès
des braconniers une peau de tigre de
sibérie se négocie au marché noir
dix mille euros alors les programmes de
protection coûte cher il faut payer des
gens pour surveiller pour lutter contre
les braconniers sa demande vraiment des
fonds les sommes investies sont
significatives
la fondation prince albert ii y
participent mais d'autres organisations
aussi mais les résultats sont payants on
peut le faire au milieu des années 90 on
ne comptait plus qu'une trentaine de
tigres de sibérie
aujourd'hui on en compte à peu près 500
peut-être un peu plus parce qu'on
soupçonne qu'il y en ait en corée du
nord mais c'est difficile d'aller les
comptes et là bas donc les programmes
paye ce qui a permis
à lui icn l'union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature de déclasser
le tigre de sibérie sur sa célèbre liste
rouge des espèces menacées de en danger
critique d'extinction a simplement en
danger alors j'en reviens à mon
introduction un artiste est là pour
poser des questions ma question c'est
deal it en france et supprimer delete
c'est un pictogramme informatique
universellement connu c'est le moyen
ordinaire de supprimer un fichier de son
ordinateur
j'ai adapté ce pictogramme banal à une
réalité tangible
tragique qui est la disparition et la
menace qui pèse sur un grand nombre
d'espèces en montrant sur des grandes
bâches accroché dans les rues ou par des
projections nocturnes des mammifères des
animaux en train de disparaître façon
très théâtral lors de la création de
toutes ses toiles dans mon atelier
j'ai photographié la progression du
travail presque image par image
ça nous a permis d'avoir d'abord de très
bonne image pour pouvoir imprimer ses
grandes bâches et ensuite en regardant
ces images de la dernière c'est à dire
où la toile est terminée jusqu'à la
première en remontant à l'envers
jusqu'au fond vide on voit l'animal
doucement disparaître
nous avons donc monté des petits
vidéogrammes qui ont été projetés pour
la première fois pendant tout l'été la
nuit sur les remparts du palais princier
les gens pouvaient voir en direct la
disparition de grands mammifères delete
fait appel à notre cerveau reptilien
quand nous voyons apparaître le
pictogramme nous sentons notre index
prêt à cliquer mais dans le même temps
nous sentons un impérieux besoin de
résister
[Applaudissements]